[Musica]
buonasera
la nostra mente per il 10 per cento è
impegnata con quello che arriva dalla
realtà esterna mentre per il restante 90
per cento del tempo è impegnata in
attività interne pensare e soprattutto
immaginare
forse alcuni di voi ne sono convinti
meglio la compagnia di un animale che ti
dedica più attenzioni che non quella di
un essere umano
gli animali vivono in stretta
connessione con la natura
non si lamentano non accusano e
soprattutto non fanno programmi per il
futuro la nostra mente invece continua
elaborare la realtà esterna
continua a lavorare la realtà esterna
attraverso una rete neuronale elabora
significati che però non sempre
equivalgono la realtà tutti gli esseri
umani sottostanno un meccanismo
preferisco lo star bene e de vito lo
star male questo meccanismo è molto
importante perché addirittura noi
abbiamo al nostro interno un altro
meccanismo all'interno della nostra
mente un meccanismo che è soprattutto
interessato alle cattive notizie di
fronte una belva feroce questo
meccanismo può aumentare le nostre
probabilità di vita attraverso emozioni
come rabbia ho paura
noi siamo informati di quello che accade
attorno a noi siamo informati della
realtà attorno
ad esempio io in questo momento su
questo palco mi sento abbastanza
tranquilla e rilassata perché perché ciò
che percepisco attorno a me corrisponde
a quanto io ho in mente di come dovrebbe
essere per stare tranquilla e serena su
questo palco ma voi vi chiederete ma
tutto questo cosa c'entra con la
gentilezza e soprattutto che cos'è la
gentilezza la gentilezza un bacio è una
carezza e l'amore oppure e sfidare la
natura per consegnare un pacco la
gentilezza innata fino a circa
trent'anni fa pensavamo che l'essere
umano era potenzialmente egoista ce lo
diceva darwin con le sue teorie
poi finalmente è arrivato rizzolati
professor rizzolati che ha scoperto i
neuroni specchio ha scoperto che ci sono
dei neuroni che si attivano quando
facciamo qualcosa ma si attivano anche
quando vediamo qualcun'altro fare la
stessa cosa
poi è arrivato un altro professore di
università israeliana in lui ha scoperto
i geni dell'altruismo
quindi la bella notizia è che la
gentilezza l'abbiamo tutti noi e nel
nostro patrimonio genetico la gentilezza
è attivata dall'empatia cognitiva che
non si tratta soltanto di sentire le
emozioni dell'altro
la tristezza
per il dolore che il mio amico esprime
con la perdita di suo padre il disgusto
che mia sorella ha espresso la scorsa
settimana quando mi ha raccontato che
mio nipote si è mangiato dei grilli
fritti comperate al supermercato
l'empatia è molto importante perché
questa empatia cognitiva ci permette di
stare connessi e stare connessi ci
permette di prenderci una pausa rispetto
a quella situazione corrente che è
quello di stare sul chi vive perché
magari succede qualcosa di pericoloso
stare connessi significa creare una
cultura condivisa una cultura condivisa
ci permette di prove approvare il
sollievo di essere compresi e di
comprendere
poi arrivano le ricerche le ricerche ci
dicono che la gentilezza se attivata a
dei benefici straordinari si risolvono
più fretta ai problemi diminuiscono i
conflitti aumenta la cerchia delle
nostre conoscenze il tono dell'umore
migliore si dorme meglio
in generale c'è un benessere psicofisico
migliore e anche ci allunga la vita
quindi identificare la gentilezza con la
buona educazione
ho dei formalisti vuoti e un po
riduttivo perché la gentilezza e
soprattutto consapevolezza e la
consapevolezza che se io non sto
connesso con te io non collaboro con te
io non cooperho conte ci saranno
svantaggi devastanti per tutti noi
se invece io copro sto connesso con te
con l'avaro allora i vantaggi saranno
magnifici per ognuno di noi
la gentilezza è importantissima perché
permette la nostra evoluzione la
gentilezza è un tema che è molto più
profondo di quello che noi pensiamo e
quello che alberoni dice la limpida
predisposizione verso l'altro e quello
che in epoca vittoriana veniva
identificato come il buon cuore essere
disponibile verso l'altro collaborare il
riconoscersi nell'altro senza
distinzioni
e poi ce lo dicono gli evoluzionisti la
gentilezza o comunque l'essere umano ha
iniziato evolvere soprattutto quando ho
iniziato a cooperare sento già qualcosa
nelle vostre testoline l'obiezione che
sta uscendo e dice sì ok ma se la
gentilezza ha questa forza perché non
siamo tutti gentili
se io vi chiedo siete gentili e dover
testoline che dico sì sono sicura che la
maggior parte di voi risponderebbe si
bene perché coloro che hanno detto sì
non ho una bella notizia perché siete
dei deboli
siete dei perdenti sì perché la nostra
società la società moderna non è molto
amante della gentilezza
anzi considera i gentili dai perdenti
delle persone che si lasciano mettere i
piedi in testa
quindi non è facile essere gentile
quindi siete dei qui perché siete deboli
perché la società non ci permette di
esprimere questa di gentilezza e quindi
di essere di godere tutti di questo di
questi vantaggi perché la gentilezza ha
bisogno tempi lenti ha bisogno di
pazienza mentre noi di pazienza non ne
abbiamo più
noi dopo cinque minuti ci viene il
sangue gli occhi come se fossimo dei
tori davanti a un drappo rosso la
gentilezza ha bisogno del qui ora adesso
mentre noi siamo proiettati nel futuro
chissà quanti di voi stanno pensando
chissà cosa mangio dopo stasera oppure a
cosa farete domani o magari qualcuno
sono già proiettate sul natale le ferie
i regali la gentilezza bisogno di queste
cose
poi ha bisogno di altri altri elementi
che ci sono portati via
ad esempio in molti multitasking ci fa
commettere tantissimi errori
e poi cosa succede ancora succede che
noi siamo costantemente continuamente
sommersi da ondate di informazioni 24
ore su 24 ore e questa cosa ci mette
l'ansia
siamo infatti siamo un popolo degli
ansiosi se non di depressi per la
fortuna delle case farmaceutiche tutta
questa continua continue ondate di
brutte notizie di emergenza climatica di
disoccupazione di violenze di terremoti
siamo sommersi e siamo in continua ansia
ci sentiamo insicuri ci sentiamo male
nella nostra pelle
ma qualcuno di noi ancora di più
qualcuno di noi si sente come se fosse
sconnesso si sente come se quella
comunità che dovrebbe accoglierlo
proteggerlo e garantirgli di realizzare
i propri sogni fosse sparita si sente
abbandonato e allora cosa succede la
nostra mente che come scopo appunto di
farci sopravvivere di mantenerci in vita
inizio a mandarli dei messaggi a questa
persona sotto stress che comincia a
dirgli devi attaccare devi difenderti
attenzione sei in pericolo
e così facendo la nostra mente attiva
gli automatismi della sopravvivenza
fuggire o attaccare
e queste persone più debole più deboli
che non riescono a mantenersi in
equilibrio
così facendo così cedendo alle richieste
da loro mente perdono quella facoltà di
immaginare quello che l'altro vede di
immaginare come l'altro vede la realtà e
perdendo a questa facoltà perde anche
l'empatia cognitiva e quindi si
disconnette completamente
sì perché non essere gentile l'essere
sgarbato per una mente che si sente
sotto assedio significa un modo per
sopravvivere in un mondo ostile per
quelle persone insicure e deboli
vulnerabili
per cui io adesso mi rivolgo a quelli
che hanno detto sì sono gentili resta
debole anzi si più deboli perché essere
gentili e l'unico modo oggi per poter
sopravvivere per rimanere connesso con
gli altri per permetterci di evolvere
non solo se tu resti deboli e gentile
dunque puoi dare all'altro l'esperienza
della gentilezza e non dimentichiamoci
che la gentilezza come le emozioni
positive sono contagiose ma vi dico
anche un'altra cosa
voi gentili cambiate la vostra
percezione perché quelle che voi
ritenete degli sgarbati sono delle
vittime sono delle persone insicure che
hanno bisogno di sicurezza
voi potete avere un obiettivo importante
nella vostra vita che è quello di
mantenervi connessi gentili ma avete una
missione quella di aiutare gli sgarbati
a passare da chiusi disconnessi
fiduciosi sgarbati aperti connessi
fiduciosi gentili ogni volta che vi
rendete conto che qualcuno e sgarbato
con voi
già dal fatto che ve ne rendete conto
capite che siete un altro livello
capite che sei scivolate vi perdete come
lui utilizzate quella famosa
immaginazione quel 90 per cento che la
nostra mente usa per immaginare la sua
realtà e quindi riconnettervi in modo
gentile con lui sì perché l'abbiamo
detto prima la gentilezza è uno dei
fattori evolutivi più importanti ma
fidatevi se la sperimentate se la
provate non ne potete fare a meno non ne
potete fare a meno perché la gentilezza
come diceva il filosofo l'imperatore
marco aurelio e la delizia più grande
dell'umanità
adesso a voi la scelta poi potete essere
il cambiamento che volete vedere nel
mondo grazie
[Applauso]